actually
anyways um
uh so there's a few of us here in bic
124
and um
including two committee members
and uh the rest of you are online so um
i want to welcome everyone to
um
a uh
doctoral dissertation defense we've
actually had a whole bunch of these in
the last uh couple months so
it's great to see
um people uh finishing their long treks
so our speaker today
is wei chun lin who uh probably most of
you know
um has been a phd student in the
department for several years and um
has now reached the
hopefully the end um
and so um i think most people know the
usual
uh approach to doctoral dissertations
the
um
like thesis defenses where there's a
public presentation public questions
then the public is dismissed and the
committee remains
and then the candidate is dismissed and
they decide if there's a successful
defense i don't want to take too much of
way chun's time but um let me just give
a brief introduction again he's been
around the department for um many
several years now as a national library
medicine
actually postdoctoral fellow although
pursuing a phd
he
originally completed his medical
training at chiang gung university in
taiwan
where he
obtained his doctor of medicine md
degree with the double major in
traditional chinese medicine he then
received the master of science in
biomedical engineering from carnegie
mellon and then he joined our department
in september 2017
and um he's going to present his
dissertation today
okay thank you for the introduction so
let me share the screen
can you guys see my screen bro
okay that's a long time not have a
talk in this um classroom
so hello everyone thank you for coming
today i'm presenting my dissertation
work application of machine learning for
glaucoma surgical outcome
using yeah data
so glaucoma is the second second leading
cause of irreversible blindness in the
world in u.s there are about two percent
of population was affected by the
glaucoma older than 40 years old
so what is glaucoma glaucoma is a group
of eye disease corrected by
progressive feature field loss and
optic nerve damage which always
related to the increased intraocular
pressure
but medication control is a primary
treatment plan for glaucoma to avoid um
program disease progression however
about 2
20 of patients eventually need glaucoma
surgery and there are several glaucoma
central surgical methods including
tropical activity tropicoloctomy
surgery
laser surgery and tropical glactomy is
one of the most common used
glaucoma surgery for the advanced
patients
in tropicolectomy surgeon will remove a
portion of trapez trabecular meshwork
and create a kernel from the inside of
eye and to the outside of i which drain
out the inside
eye fluid and decrease the intraocular
pressure however according to the study
reported trabeculectomy surgical
value rates about like 28 to 32 percent
so there are some different definitions
of surgical value in general surgical
value was defined as a patient's need to
reoperation or showing consistent high
op or low iop after three months of
primary surgery so those patients might
need to take glaucoma medication
continuously
surgical values are mainly correlated to
the post-operative complication
including the
high iop or low iop or other factors
scarring is the most common cause for
the elevated iop and the bleep leakage
overfiltration
is common cause of the low iop
complications
uh some other
communication may be noticed like
infection lipid
malignant glaucoma in this study we will
focus on the
communication related to the high iop or
low iop since the occurrence of other
factors
post-operative management is crucial and
time sensitive the goal period of the
post-operative management is about two
to three months after the theory
physicians may adjust their treatment
plan and the frequency of the visit for
the patient with higher risk of
complication
for example physicians may decrease the
steroid dosage or delay the laser suture
lysis time for the patient with higher
risk of coronary hypothetically on the
other hand um physicians may adjust
their treatment for the patient with
higher chance of scarring they might use
post-operative anti-fibrotic aging like
5fu or use higher dose of
topic steroid
so overall the success of tropicolactomy
surgery highly depends on the
post-operative care and the goal period
is around two to three months after the
surgery post-operative management is
complicated and may be contrary due to
different cause of complication and the
complexity of surgical recoveries and
the different means of
operative care makes predicting
long-term glaucoma surgical outcome more
challenging therefore an assistant tool
for predicting which patient has a
higher
risk of long-term surgical value with
different costs
will be needed
so my first aim was to access the
possible ehr data that correlated to the
glaucoma surgical outcome
and i did a systematic literature review
focus on the ai application um for idc's
using ehr data
next my following m will address some
knowledge gap and
limitation we found in specific m1 so in
the n2 i developed several machine
learning and deep learning model using
both structure and unstructured ehr data
to predict multi-class surgical outcome
including surgical success surgical
value due to high iop and surgical value
due to low iop
for the inode for the final m i try to
explain the developed model in the n2
and to identify the important features
or
explore the impact of this feature on
the prediction result
here is the
overview of our study in m1 uh i did a
literature review and data assessment in
the end to develop several machine
learning and deep learning model and the
model performance was evaluated by
several evaluation metrics in the entry
we did a model explanation to explore
the important feature and
their impact on the predictions
so for the m1
the systematically lecture literature
review focus on the ai application using
hr data for the eye disease and some
risk factor of glaucoma progression and
surgery
um also i explored a different format of
ehr data including the structural ehr
data on structured data and medication
list
the review literature review work was
published in translational physician
science and technology journal we found
several knowledge gap and limitation in
previous study
based on our literature review few study
focus on surgical outcome prediction for
glaucoma patient and there are several
notable knowledge gap first most studies
use the single miniature such as the
iop before the surgery or the early
post-operative biop try to predict the
long-term outcome
however there are many factors might
correlate to the surgical outcomes such
as images visual acuity patients
condition chronic disease medication use
or surgery itself so use single measures
sometimes it's questionable
and the previous study focus on the
binary surgical outcome that means
predict the surgery is success or fail
but the treatment plan for the
post-operative complication can be
different as like high opt scarring
patient and hypotenuse patient they need
a totally contrary treatment plan
and the
previous study did not include
intraoperative information some study
used the data before the surgery some
used to date up after surgery in the
small period but it's laking the
information about the um during the
surgery and the sample size is not an
issue
most study the sample size is smaller
than 200 eyes
so there's still
really a need to
develop a tool to assist with prediction
of surgical value due to iop changes
yeah
sorry about that
so the first step for the ehr data
assessment we identified the target
population for our study trapigolectomy
performed at kci institute from 2010 to
2021.
around 1500 eyes in certain hundred
glaucoma patients were included and the
inclusion criteria was listed below as
mentioned before our surgical outcome
focus on surgical success value due to
high iop and value due to low iop
sorry
so for the structured ehr data we select
50 features including four groups
patient's condition and eye mixtures i
mean should include a multi-time point
of intra-ocular pressure and visual
acuity and medication including the
oral medication or eye drop for the
glaucoma or the oral medication for the
chronic disease like hypertension or
diabetes and some other information
related to the operation itself
and feature selection was knowledge
based and data-driven linear imputation
was used to handle the missing numeric
data
in addition some variables are
incomplete or mislea missing in the
structured format such as conjunctiva
report or maximizing dosage are used
during the procedure mitomycin c is a
pretty important anti-fibrotic agent
that used during the surgery that help
patients
decrease the risk of scarring after
surgery so we need to extract this
information from the progress node or
surgical node in the
free text format so we developed several
regular expression based tools to
extract information and close validate
information from the structure format
and unstructured format to improve the
data quality
for the unstructured ehr data we focus
on the surgical note surgical node
contains intraoperative information and
might be useful for the long-term
outcome prediction
after data cleaning we tokenize our road
tax and develop a custom where to factor
model using the sibo master and we
create a 50 dimensions work vector then
this what factor will input to the
prediction model later
here is the example of surgical
knowledge physicians may recall the
modernizing dosage the time used and the
patient's condition during the surgery
uh surgery technique to use the blood
laws and some other information during
the procedure so um here's the example
for the centrifugal
note
so here's an example of surgical node
pre-processing the road tags will clean
up and the custom
stop words and punctuation was removed
and those tags will tokenize and then
each token will link to an index in the
custom of vocabulary and those index
number will convert to the tensor format
which is a array-like format that's used
for the deep learning model like pytorch
or tensorflow
the last part we try to
explore the usability of medication
lists so the first question is is
medication less accurate to answer this
question we manually review 150 progress
note and we found some discrepancies
between the progress node and the
medication list
um
since the manual review is time
consuming and labor intensive so we
decide uh develop a nlp tool to extract
the medication information
so we develop a natural language based
model for automatically extract active
medication and medication adherence in
the free tax progress note and
demonstrate a prototype
medication reconciliation tool using the
development model this work was
published at any new symposium
conference in 2021
here is the flowchart of the overall
overview of the study the first step we
manually annotate 500 progress known and
data was displayed into training and
testing and then we used a net entity
recognition
to develop
model to extract active medication
the net entity recognition
as a type of natural language process
technique seeks to locate
um classifying entities in the text into
predefined categories in our study it's
like medication nand frequency or dosage
and we use spacey library in python
environment and we create a
convolutional neural network to predict
each net entities
the model evaluation was using f1 score
precision record and the micro aperture
score for
all entities
and we also developed a prototype
medication reconciliation tool
here is the example of annotate nodes
including all entities such as drug name
the root of administration
prescription frequency the dosage of the
drug
medications trends the duration and the
medication adherence and medication use
term
drug name contains generic and branding
and abbreviation current medicaid use
current medication use term was labeled
as a
drug use and with the blue collar which
is pretty important because if we use
this term to identify the following
medications active uses not recording
like past history medication
history
so there are some examples of this is
this label like
eye drop i imagine start using taking or
continuous
the table shows the result for the per
entity and average score for the all
entities
the um we can see the the model
has a pretty accurate lead to extract
medication related entities such as drug
name frequency route dosage and strength
but model shows the lower performance on
the duration and adherence
the difference might be come from
the limited sample size in the trending
data or the
variety of wording for some labels
so overall the model was very accurate
at identifying medication but less so
for adherence and the duration and the
model performance is similar to the best
performing published nop model for
medication extraction
with our developed model we can go back
to applied model as a medication
reconciliation tool first
the ner model extract the patient's
medication and the drug use label the
drug use label was used to identify
whether the medications are currently
used then the drug name are standardized
based on the ark's known ingredient
finally the medication data was
reconciled with the medication list and
the mismatched medication of flag we
applied this tool on 150 progress node
and got a f1 score around 95 percent
so from our medication study we found
the medication list might not be
accurately recorded so if we want to
include the medication information as a
predictor for the outcome prediction
um
that's some issue for using in each
unique medication as a predict because
that will generate a pretty loose
data set so we need to do some
dimension reduction
um in our cohort patient in the
medication this patient taking more than
thousands of unique medications
including the common medication or
chronic disease oral medication
so here's an example um with design use
categorized medication based on their
pharmacology mechanism so there are 10
unique post-glanding eye drops in the
medication list and if we categorize
them based on the mechanism then they'll
be narrowed down to one group so by this
way we can reduce the dimension
dimensionality and
avoid some
medication list in accuracy issue
for a prediction model
here the key takeaway of the m1
first both validate ehr data with
structure and unstructured format could
improve the data quality and the
surgical nodes contain intraoperative
information it might be useful for the
outcome prediction and medication this
accuracy was questionable for glaucoma
patients and the developed nlp tool can
be used to help with medication
reconciliation
and the categorized medication based on
their pharmacology mechanism might be
useful for
outcome prediction model
in the end to to address the challenging
and the knowledge gap for predicting
glaucoma surgical outcomes i developed
several machine learning and deep
learning model using both structure and
unstructured ehr data
to predict the glaucoma patient with
higher risk of surgical value
after 30 days of primary treatment
since the treatment plan for the
surgical value might be contrary or
different due to their cause so we try
to predict three class as our outcome
surgical success surgical value due to
low iop or surgical value due to high
iop
um surgical value it's with like
scarring and continuous like high lp is
easy to understand but if after the
surgery um the continuous hypotenuse or
the lower iop can also can be a um
clinical
emergency condition and mind some
procedure intervention like needling or
consider reoperation so try to predict
those two different groups surgical
value is pretty important uh rather than
just predict surgical success or fail um
besides in our study we excluded
reoperation
uh cases caused by the infection and
bleed dysthesia since
symbol size is really small
let's quickly take a look at our
strategic design we did a data
extraction and preprocessing in the
first step and we developed several
machine learning and deep learning model
and the model was evaluated by several
evaluation metrics
here is the list of of the model we
developed
for the using structured ehr data we
developed five machine learning models
including artificial neural neural
network random forest actually boost
support vector machine and logistical
regression
with elastic net penalty and the random
force shows the best performance use
only structured ehr data
and the
text classification model was developed
using the surgical nodes including the
one dimension conduction on your network
model by the directional long short-term
manual remodel and transformer encoder
block classification model the transform
former encoder block classification
model shows the best performance
and we also developed a early fusion
multimodal with transformer encoder
block classification model try to handle
the
structure data and structure data at the
same time
here is the early fusion multi-model
architecture
for the structured hr data the
continuous
feature was normalized and the
categorical feature would convert to the
one hop factor
and the surgical nodes was handled by
the transformer block with the setting
list here with 10 heads and 12 layers
and the hidden units is 768 with dropout
rate 0.1 the output of the transformer
block will concatenate with the
structured eardr data you know two more
dense layer with the battery
normalization there and the dropout
layer were concatenated but that would
connect it
and finally we use the softmax function
to predict three class outcomes
the hyperparameter we use for the
optimize model was list here
in general there are three common
strategies for the deep learning model
fusion
early fusion intermediate fusion and lay
fusion in our study we found early
fusion shows the
best performance for our model
in the previous slide we showed the
architecture of module neural network
where we use the transformer block to
extract information from the text data a
transformer model is a neural network
with the mechanism of
attention and position embedding which
is popular using many fields such as
natural language processing and computer
vision
for a classification problem we only
used
encoder block to extract information we
don't need a decoder block which used
for the sequence to sequence model
so in in the um
in transformer encoder block text data
was conferred to the pre-trend embedding
metrics and then the position factor is
add to the embedded metrics in order to
enhance and maintain position of the
words
in the text another important part is
multi-head attention which contained
number of different attention layer in
order to find out the attention words
from the sequence and all this layer
work in parallel so in our study we use
the 10 hats in the prediction model and
at the output of each encoder is passed
to the next one and the overall
output of the encoder block uh can
connect to the linear layer like here or
concatenate to other input data in a
multi-model design like our study
in a transformer block
multi-head attention and positional
embedding both provide information about
the relationship between the different
words and contextual meaning
therefore the transformer block can
trend in peril and manage tax data in a
non-sequential way so compared to the
other uh recurrent neural network like
long short-term memory they treat the
tax as a sequential data
each by each word by words so using
transformer block can avoid some problem
of forgetting of passive information in
a long text in our study even our
sample size of the surgical nodes is not
big the transformer encoder block can
still work well to extract information
from the loan
from those tags
our data set was randomly split into
eighty percent as training and twenty
percent at testing and a five-fold
cross-validation was used to avoid
overfitting uh and to the hyperparameter
the model performance was evaluated by
auc score f1 score precision record and
macro attitude scores
here's some explanation of the
evaluation metrics
accuracy determine the how correct value
are predicted and recall is the ratio of
correctly predicted class to the all
actual class and position is the ratio
of correctly predicted class to the
total predict class at the f1 scroll
take care the information from both
precision and recall and get an average
number
from from these two majors
and
roc curve is a grade showing the
performance of a classification model at
all
classifications ratio and the area under
the roc curve shows the model ability to
distinguish different class
um here we only shows the
best performance model from each data
format
so blue shows the using both structure
and structural reactor data and red is
used as structure hr data only and the
green color shows the um use the
surgical node only
so we found the
multi-model neural network with
transformer encoder block shows the
highest
auc score and f1 scroll so which
indicator combined interoperated
information from surgical node with
important structure ehr data may bring
more information for the surgical
outcome prediction
this slide shows a detailed information
about the multi-modal
neural network result
the model has a good good ability to
identify the iop cases or low iop cases
surgical value with a recall score
higher than 50 percent which means the
model can correctly identify uh more
than 50 percent of surgical value case
so for example in our test data there
are 36 case with the high iop surgical
value and our model can correctly
identify 20 of them
however the model shows the lower
performance for
for the precision position for the low
iop
prediction
so overall the multimodal with both
structure and unstructured ehr data
bring a decent result for multi-class
prediction
so here are three
uh key
key takeaway from our specific end to
first
multi
multimodal neural network with both
structure and our structure ehr data can
be used to predict the multi-class
surgical outcome of the primary tropical
lactomy comparing to the previous study
uh even try to predict the multi-class
that's a little bit more complicated
than the binary outcome our model still
has a higher uh
auc score and f1 score
and the surgical nose content
intraoperative
information is used for the surgical
outcome prediction
and the surgical recoveries
of trapecolectomy are complicated and
hard to predict for the long term
outcome so develop model could be an
assistant tool for the clinical decision
making
in the last m we
do an extension study from the specific
n2 we try to explain the developed model
in the n2 and to identify important
feature and their effect on the
prediction result
also the multimodal neural network shows
the
higher auc score and have better
performance currently there are no
reliable model explainer tool for the
multi-model design
prediction model so in this
in this study we focus on the best
performance machine learning model using
only structured ehr data we apply the
model explainer tool shape on the random
first model to explore the importance
and impact of the features
shape value is against a radical
approach to explain the output of a
machine learning model the goal of shape
is to explain the prediction of any data
point x by computing the contribution of
each feature to the prediction
with the shape value we can calculate
the marginal contribution of each
features and get its impact on the
prediction
the basic idea comes from shapely value
it's a solution concept in cooperative
game theory which was introduced by leo
shapley in 1951.
here's a
illustration example of shapely value a
0 we have full player they work together
for a
cargo competition and they get the word
and have some payout so the question is
how can we fairly distribute this payout
and the shift lead value was used to
calculate the marginal contribution for
each player and then we can fairly
distribute this payout so this idea
applies to the machine learning so in a
trend model each feature will work as a
player and the
machine learning model will be the game
and
and the prediction will be the payout so
by this way we can
calculate the marginal contribution for
each feature for the prediction
here is the equation of the sharply
value phi represents the shapely value
of a feature i for the one data point
and small n is the total number of
features
uh big m without i contained all the
possible feature subsets not containing
the feature i and
the big ass is the one feature subset
from the big n the number of s is the
size of subset features and v x is the
trim model prediction function and small
x is the factor of feature value of a
data point
and the red red angle shows the marginal
contribution and the blue red angle is
the weight of for the combinations
so overall sharply value is used to
calculate the local feature contribution
for each data point and we can also get
a global interpretation like feature
importance
based on the aggregation of shapely
value
the figure shows the global future
importance in our random forest model
since we want to know the global
importance we can average the absolute
shape values per feature across the data
and feature with larger absolute shape
value are important and then will sort
the feature by
decreasing the importance
so in in this plot the most uh important
factor is intraocular pressure two to
four weeks after the surgery
which is similar to previous findings
some study that showed
the post-operative iop day 30
during that
day period is the most important
predictor for the long-term high iop
and some other factors like patient's
age the medication use and the previous
surgery are also important
in this important
future importance plot
also the feature important plot is
useful but how can we tell the effect of
each feature for each class
so we can use the shape summary plot
here is the
uh shape summary plot in our study for
the surgical value to do the iop
so in the shape plot each point um is a
shape value uh of a feature for a data
point and the y-axis is determined by
the feature
and
the features are older according to
their importance and access shows the
shape value and the color represent the
value of the feature it's not for the
shape values for the feature value and
the overlapping point are jetted in the
y-axis
so the feature summary plot shows the
basic relationship between the value of
feature and the impact on the prediction
for each class
it won't
dig deeply for the independent or
a single feature and theoretical
relation to the prediction outcome and
the has a more clear clearly
relationship plot we can use the shape
dependence plot
this figure shows the feature dependent
for the iop value
in two to four weeks after surgery is
the most important
feature in our study
so the shape feature depends on plot
shows a local feature importance overall
feature value of the data the y-axis is
the shape value um it's in indicator
impact on prediction and the x-axis is
the value of the feature so um and each
point are the
data point specific data point we we use
in the
shape model that can be the test data or
training data here we use the test data
to explain the model
and in the dependent plot the positive
shape value
means increase the predict risk of the
output class and the negative shape
value means decrease the predict risk of
the output class
actually in the shape summary plot each
row was projecting from the point of the
shape dependence plot on the y-axis and
recoloring by the feature value
in the following slide we will show
several
summary plot and dependent plot about
about our important feature finding in
the
random forest model here is again the
post operative
week two to four iop minges so we can
see a clear linear relationship between
the feature value and their prediction
effect on the
surgical value due to a high iop and the
higher iop increase their predict risk
and low iop decrease the predict risk
here's another example of important
feature as a binary uh inputs
so the pros glanding medication if
patient did not use this in
so that will increase the predicted risk
of the surgical value due to a high iop
and uh
um decrease the risk if patients use the
prostaglandin and the the
prior cataract surgery feature shows the
country effect
compared to the
post glanding eye drops
and here is a another feature
with less important which is the
post post-operative iop day 2 to 14 so
we can see there is no clear
relationship and
uh with pretty
uh the range of the shape is pretty
small that's
this is the same as clinical finding
since after the primary treat uh surgery
the iop is always fluctuation during the
first two weeks and so that's the last
projection power is
um yeah
and here's the summary plot for the
surgical value due to the low iop right
now it's not for the high iop
so we can see the um post operative week
two to four iop still the most important
one and shows a linear relationship but
compared to the high iop case the linear
relationship is not as clear as the high
op
and
in the lower iop prediction low iop
surgical value prediction
the
lower
uh low iop during that period increase
the predict risk
here is a proglaming eye drop for the
surgical value due to low iop so
contrary to the
surgical value due to high ilp
postglanding use before the surgery will
increase the predict risk of surgical
value due to low iop
and other than the surgical value plot
we can also explore the surgical success
plot so here is well again the
post-operative week two to four iop is
still the most important one but in its
dependency plot we can see the
um there's no clear linear relationship
and we can found
there's many
points that has the same feature value
but their effect can be positive or
negative so which indicates if you want
to use a single value even it's the most
important one in our model
make the prediction for the long term
outcome will be pretty difficult
we also notice that age shows a linear
relationship for the surgical
success rate senior patients increase
their predict probability of surgical
success and a younger patient should
decrease the
predict probability of surgical success
so from n3 we found the iop measure in
the two to four weeks after surgery is
the most important predictor of the long
term surgical outcome for both structure
value so and which is similar to the
previous study finding and we thought we
also found some interesting features
like post-glanding eye drop used before
the surgery and prior cataract surgery
or the
linear relationship of the
age and
the surgical success rate
this feature is haven't been cleared the
or the result is controversial so it can
be a possible risk factor of the
surgical outcome for the future study
the key takeaway from this n3 is machine
learning model with the structured ehr
data has a predictive power for surgical
outcome and the model explainer can
provide insight into the important
features associated with the multi-class
outcome
and the identified factors can be used
to improve the clinical care or help
with the direction for a future clinical
study however there are several
limitations need to be noticed also our
data set was one of the largest clinical
observation data set with detailed
information about
trapezolectomy outcomes the sample size
is still limited due to the nature of
the study in a single institute
since the study was provided a single
issue the result might not be
generalizable to other healthcare
system
and we
currently don't have a reliable model
explainer for the multi-model neural
network model explanation
in the future to improve the accuracy
and the generalizability of the model we
plan to
combine image data such as oct
data before the surgery in our
multi-modal neural network and include
data from other institute
also because of the novel finding from
the model explainer we are planning to
perform a retrospective clinical study
focused on the traditional risk factor
with
multi-class outcomes
so in summary my first study explored
the ai application using ear chart data
for eye dcs showing there were limited
study focused on glaucoma surgical
outcome prediction with several notable
limitations
and i clean and validate the structure
hr data with our fracture ehr data
improve the data quality and develop a
custom word embedding model for the
surgical node
also i figure out the accuracy issue of
the medication list for glaucoma
patients and develop a medication
reconciliation tool using the natural
language algorithm and the usability of
medication list for the prediction model
was also
explored
overall this work has the implication in
improving the data quality and the
usefulness for the medication data in
both research and clinical care
in the end
sorry in the end too i developed several
machine learning and deep learning model
with structure and unstructured ehr data
to predict the multi-class surgical
outcomes
um this study is one of the first and
largest clinical
observation data set
with detailed information about the
tropicolactomy outcomes uh combined both
structure and unstructured ehr data also
the usefulness of surgical nodes as a
predictor in the multi-class outcome
prediction model was presented it has a
potential to apply this
concept to the other clinical specialty
and the multi uh money model prediction
neural network could uh could correctly
identify 50 percent or more surgical
value cases
so it can be an assistant tool for
clinical decision making
and lastly in our specific entry we
developed the model explainer for our
random force model to identify risk
factors associated with the high iop or
low iop surgical value and explore their
importance and their effect on the
surgical outcomes
so i would like to thank you my mentor
dr mitchell weber and dr michael chen
and all my communities thank you for
your time your support and your guide
and really appreciate it
also i'd like to thank you all my
research group members
jimmy adam aaron isaac and ernest i got
a lot of help and many pleasant hour
work with you guys
and thank you for the wonderful staff
and faculty in oshu at d mice and the
kci institute especially i want to thank
you diane andrea virginia and abby i got
a lot of help
along the way
besides i want to thank you my fellow
students and the
exam cohort rose lady mina da and chris
and all demise fellows
and i want to thank again for
my mentor dr mitchell cribber for all
your support and your insightful
suggestion for my projects also i would
like to thank you again for the michael
chan dr michael chen and dr karen eden
for advising me to start my phd journey
and support supporting me along the way
and finally
i'd like to thank you my
family especially for my wife my parents
and my sister in the founding front
and i
national library of medicine
yeah so that's my work thank you for
listening
stop sharing your screen so let me see
if those questions and the next i have a
question uh let me start sharing
yeah that way just so we can see them
oops
sync is here yeah
are people still there
yeah
but not the slides but the webex
um
yeah
the webex is in my monitor but like
okay yeah
okay so then i'm gonna quit out of this
some connection issues
okay you can let me just take a look at
it yeah um
so my my screen is still the webex oh
okay interesting the the screen here is
actually okay
well let me um let let me uh and are
there um
so people can either type questions in
the chat or can unmute um
but i'm gonna take the prerogative and
ask the first
question
um
the the medication reconciliation so you
said there was a 36 percent
error rate
uh discrepancy describing for our manual
review 150 progress note
and um
but so between what was in the progress
note and like the medication list or
yeah because we included some um
counterpart i mean not the uh it's some
like artificial
fluid or some knots yeah like hospital
prescription medication as our list and
what was the direction of the errors was
it like um some error come from like
duplicate prescription and prescription
actually stop but not showing in the
medication list and some other is like
patient take medication from the other
pharmacology of pharmacy but they're not
taking medication from the os at you so
the medication doesn't list this many
okay and so the
so your gold standard then was what was
in the note
yeah yeah would you assume um it's not
can be like purely goes in there but we
believe that especially we try to
extract active medication so that means
like physicians will recover something
like drug use patients like taking or
starves so we try to focus on the active
medication we assume that's more
reliable yeah okay and and so and then
you kind of um um you sort of
narrowed it down into categories which
actually makes a lot of sense you know
um
you know so i mean i i guess um um well
that kind of clarifies things and i i
mean i i guess maybe the question is um
um
you know is there concern about
the um
well
you i i guess your assumption is that
you're mapping the different drugs into
the specific categories and so that that
is what goes into your model preserve
some information
well actually in the beginning we try to
treat each medication unique medication
there's some embedding method similar to
the word embedding so we try to work to
factor treat each medication as a word
and each feeds it as a sentence or
recommendation system to get the
medication embedding but probably
due to the sample size and then there
are too many unique medications we input
this medication embedding in our
production model but they cannot
converge and make things
mess up so we figure out that's probably
like issue of medication list itself or
the the noise generated during we trend
the medication embedding but it's
interesting try yeah yeah okay yeah i
mean it just goes to show the the
challenges of working with uh ehr datas
is just another
example of it are there other
questions yeah why don't you go ahead
and um i don't know if there's any
further
up and there's a few
congratulations and so forth um
but there's a um a question from nate
there
yeah for the our transfer inc uh now to
ask oh i don't need to read again yeah
so we we don't use the pre-trained model
we just use the um transformer encoder
block that that architecture and with
our pre-trained 50 dimension wood
embedding to extract this information to
con concatenate with our structural heat
char data in our prediction model so we
did not use a pre-trained pre-trained
bird
if anyone has any questions they can
also unmute
maybe i'll i'll ask one more question um
your your
um
recall precision f score were
were good but not
perfect
so um
what are the
um
ramifications of that if people are
going to use this tool clinically
currently i think um
it can it can be just if that applies
into the clinical setting it can just be
a assistant tool to so probably provide
some probability of the patient has a
higher risk of high op or low iot for
the long term so still need to
physician and human expert to make the
judgment to did i agree this
probability or not
yeah
okay
and then since the like
limited symbol size well thinking is a
possible include like of oct data before
surgery or some
collaborate with other institutions in
enlarged sample size
any other questions out there
okay well if not we can uh we can leave
waychon to his committee they may have
some additional questions um
uh this is really great work and um it's
really interesting uh to see
you know kind of a real world clinical
application of
machine learning like this so um
i'll look forward to future
endeavors so
we we can excuse including myself the
non-members of the committee and then
you guys can take it from there